Ми раді вітати вас в офісі європейської
солідарності і сьогодні маємо брифінг за
участі наших адвокатів адвокатів які
супроводжують Петра Олексійовича
Порошенка а також допомагають і
депутатам зараз нашої політичної сили
спрямувати позови певні про що
стосуються відповідальності певних
посадових осіб за свою бездіяльність Я
думаю почнемо з вас пане ну всім та
Добрий день Ми хочемо тримати
суспільство в курсі що ніхто не
залишиться непокараний за кричуще
порушення Закону ми знаємо коли пятого
президента не
випустили не не допустили перетину через
державного кордон України по без всяких
НАТО підстав і відповідно були Наші
звернення ми про це одразу заявили
одразу після цього випадку зокрема було
наша заява про кримінальне
правопорушення вчи збоку як працівників
прикордонної Державної прикордонної
служби так і осіб з керівництва
парламенту а саме першого заступника
голови Верховної Ради який незаконно
скасував розпорядження голови Верховної
Ради про відрядження Петра Порошенка за
кордон до Польщі Сполучених
Штатів і це наша заява про кримінальне
правопорушення була подана до офісу
Генерального прокурора і такий
оперативний іноді офіс Генерального
прокурора Як завжди Це вже традиція в
подібних випадках абсолютно нуль реакції
відповідно бездіяльність офісу
генерального прокурорамає скаржена до
суду і буде вже судовий процес і ми
чекаємо на рішення суду відповідно до
закону поводиться Львівський окружний
адміністративний суд куди було звер
направлено нами позов до чому Львівський
суд тому що два відповідачі відповідач
перший - це сьомий прикордонник
Карпатський загін західного
регіонального управління Державної
прикордонної служби те службові особи
якого прикордонники безпосередньо не
пропустили Петра Порошенка через кордон
і другий відповідач - це перший
заступник голови Верховної Ради України
пан Корнієнко Олександр Сергійович який
виніс незаконне розпорядження про
скасування відрядження Петра Порошенка
за кордон оскільки це були скоординовані
дії і від саме в результаті цих дій
незаконного розпорядження про скасування
відрядження і потім рішення
прикордонників про відмову в перетинні
державного кордону то у нас два
відповідачі позивач відповідно до закону
має право обирати суд до якого
звертатися ми Звернулися до Львівського
окружного адміністративного суду маємо
зараз ухвалу про
відкриття провадження в адміністративній
справі ухвала датована 18 грудням цього
року і в цій ухвалі то то точно
відповідно до Кодексу адміністративного
судочинства зобов'язано відповідчів а
саме першого заступника голови Верховної
Ради України не корнієнка Олександра
Сергійовича зобов'язана подати усі
докази та документи що стали підставою
для прийняття спільноного рішення
відповідно і для сьомого прикордонного
загону теж суд своєю ухвалою зобов'язав
надати всі Докази і документи на
підставі яких вони прийняли це незаконне
рішення про відмову перетині державного
кордону п'ятим Президентом України
Справа в тому що зараз ми бачимо про це
ще ми будемо говорити Як скоївши це Ну
на мою на моє переконання навіть
кримінальне
правопорушення вчинивши перешкоди для
діяльності народного депутата України
п'ятого президента Зараз ці люди
намагаються якось приховати як кажуть
замисти сліди і
приховати підстави чого саме вони це
робили і зокрема приховують певні
документи листи і все таке інше
пов'язане з цією історією Ми повинні
чітко сказати що ухвала суду яка
зобов'язує їх ці документи надати вона є
вони повинні її виконувати ця ухвала
Львівського окружного адміністратовного
суду вона відкрита є в реєстрі судових
рішень кожен може з нею ознайомитися це
дуже сподіваюся що пан Корнієнко не буде
нам всім розповідати що він про це
рішення Нічого не знає а навпаки
готуватиметься до суду і надасть до суду
всі документи які змусили його відверто
явно порушити
закон Так в нас зараз відбудеться
розголошення певної таємниці яку
наше Шановні колеги з служби безпеки
України з керівництва Верховної Ради
дуже хотіло би не
розголошувати Я розумію що це наш цей
інцидент на польському кордоні він
відбувся лише три тижні тому але під час
війни Ми не можемо сподіватися що люди
пам'ятатимуть навіть таки нещедальні
події тому нагадую як воно було все
почалося з цього листа Це пан Корнієнко
посилаючись на лист з позначкою ДСК
тобто для службового користання це такий
певний грів хоча й не таємно але він
забезпечує
певну певний певну відсутність доступу
до цього документу тих осіб яких апарат
Верховної Ради не хоче до нього
допускати посилаючись на цей лист він
29го листопада наказує апарату Верховної
Ради
скасувати скасувати
розпорядження голови Верховної Ради
стпанчука про відрдження Петра Порошенка
до сполучення штатів і до
Польщі на підставі того матеріалу який
підготував апарат Верховної ради
посилаючись на лист від
корнієнка за підписом корнієнка це трохи
виглядає як шерені а насправді це такий
важливий маркер він маркує
ту ситуацію що пан корнеєнко особисто
контролював все провадження з цими
документами він не випускав цю ситуацію
зруку а він він скасував на що він точно
не мав права бо скасувати розпорядження
голови Верховної Ради може тільки
Верховна Рада як така голосуванням в
залі кількістю не менше 300 депутатів
але каєнко його скасовує що призводить
до того що Петра Порошенка 1 грудня не
випускають у відряджені Сполучені Штати
і у Польщу
А ось як це прокоментував сам пан
Корнієнко це цитата з сайту Української
правди він каже що вони були вимушені
скасувати
відрядження Порошенка тому що до них
дійшов надійшов цей лист з
сбоу останні три тижні ми з колегами
пробували дістати копію цього листа бо
для службового користування він чи не
для службового Він стосується
безпосередньо прав Петра Порошенка і
прав тої частини суспільства яку Він
представляє у Верховній Раді Як лідер
опозиційної Партії на нам це не вдалося
нам цю копію не видали нам навіть не
видали нормальну відповідь чому вони це
не не не віддаються це така розмова
виключно на словах що також в принципі
незаконно
але ми вже дізналися в процесі цього
нашого діалогу що насправді 29 листопаду
пан корнієнто не виконував обов'язки
голови вирховної
Ради з
цього скріншоту ви витикає
що на той час принаймні на частину 29-го
Нехай вони самі пояснюють якщо вони там
передавали цю булаву але Принаймні з
того що ми бачимо 29 листопада
виконувала обов'язки голови Верховної
Ради тимчасово пані Олена ндраті вона
вязувала документи я які вона мала
віязувати виключно якщо вона виконувала
на той час обов'язки спої і саме завдяки
тому що в нас є ця охвала саме завдяки
тому що ми переко ні що хоч вони цього і
дуже не хочуть але вони будуть
зобов'язані нам віддати цей документ ми
зараз розголошуємо його зміст це не
безпосередньой той документ це зміст
який викладено людиною яка мала до нього
доступ ви бачите що тут важливо ми потім
побачимо інший скріншот я вам покажу що
Ми наразі насправді тайниц яка
стосувалась би безпосередньо
резидуальної діяльності контрезидуально
того що СТО стосується безпосередньо
нормальна прація СБ так насправді ми не
розголошуємо єдине що є таємницею яку
наші партнери дуже не хотіли б щоб ми
розкривали є те що в цьому листі нема
прізвища Порошенка і нема прізвище О бо
я нагадую Як цю ситуацію подавали
а подавало суспільство подавали так що
Порошенка були плани зустрітися з
орбаном і Якщо б він зустрівся з орбаном
напередодні АА
рішення про розпочаток процесу прийняття
України до Європейського Союзу Це було б
використано російською ісон і це було
дуже шкодливо для України а ви бачите що
в цьому листі і ми знаємо точно що це ми
його не
редагували ця позначка що там останній
абзац дослідно це саме тому що він
записувався без можливості безпосередньо
знімати ко той факт що в цьому листі
листі нема прізвища Порошенко і нема
прізвища обина дуже чітко маркирує певну
ситуацію я вам зараз поясню яку
Дивіться це Пояснення від пана
корнієнка відразу після того як стало
відомо що він зірвав візит Петра
Порошенка до Сполучених Штатів Він
пояснює що він був змушений це зробити
тому що так хотіло СБ і це Пояснення це
реліз пресслужби служби безпеки України
які кажуть що Ну ми так ми повідомили
керівництво Верховної Ради і і Кабмін і
офісу президента що існує Інформація що
буде якесь російське ПСО Але ж вони мали
змогу на свій розсуд врахувати це своїй
роботі тобто на той час на 1 грудня коли
вибухнув скандал вони переводиять
стрілки один на одного далі вже другий
ст е це для порівняння зліва це перший
від першого грудня другій Лиз 2 грудня -
це вже звіт про поважну перемогу вони
зірвали операцію російської ПСО Вони
знали що якщо Порошенко зустрівся з
орбаном це безпосередньо Було
використано для дискредитації
керівництва України тощо тощо тощо тобто
вони молодці і в принципі комієнко він
вже не на свій Ростов це використав він
то також
моводиться і якщо ви покладете цей
другий
реліз який вже звіт про перемогу звіт
про вдало
спецоперацію поруч з тим листом який
насв надійшов до Верховної Ради ви
побачите що насправді в корнієнка якщо
він керувався виключно цим листом не
було жодного шансу зрозуміти
що йдеться саме про Порошенка саме про
лустони І що він має скасувати подорож
Порошенка до Сполучених Штатів і до
Польщі де не було Орбана Він знав про це
конієнко знав про цю ситуацію Він знав
що він скасовує відрядження
саме в Сполучені Штати де Порошенко мав
спілкуватися з конгресменами які
доси не прийняли рішення про продовження
фінансування допомоги Україні а і ви
бачити що вам
брешуть заступник перший заступник
голови Верховної Ради пан Корнієнко
дезінформує суспільство про те чому саме
він скасував підрядження яке вже було
прийнято а Служба безпеки України
викрівлює справжню свою справжній зміст
своєї комунікації з керівництвом
Верховної ради на жаль це доводить дуже
сумну для нас всіх ситуацію це означає
що те що ми вважали славіллям якого
допустився один з керівників Верховної
Ради насправді є координацією суцільною
координацію між першим заступником
голови Верховної Ради і головою служби
безпеки України васелим
Я не буду наразі надавати власна
інтерпретації того чому така координація
виникла і Як так сталося що Верховна
Рада парламент який в жодній ситуації
навіть В умовах воєнного
стану не має Таким чином координувати
Свою діяльність з спецслужбою чому саме
так сталося але я констатую що
суспільство
продали це під фальшивим прапором вся
все обговорення і в перші дні коли
відбувся не випуск
Порошенка до Польщі і потім і навіть в
останні дні коли вкидують інформацію про
те що начебто Порошенко чини особисто
від орбано отримав гроші хоча це був
стандартний звіт про отримання грошей
через
облігації урядово облігації Угорщини які
там були не тільки Угорщини там були
інші країни вам це продають як доказ чи
може аргумент чи може натяг на те що в
цій ситуації Порошенко мав якісь
контакти зро і це не неправда навіть
вони своєї закритої комунікації яку вони
сподівалися не показувати нікому навіть
вони цього не пишуть малюк знав коли він
писав цього листа знав що він не може
написати що в нього є інформація Що
Порошенко домовився якось там зорганом
скомунікувати на користь російської тому
він неписав так обережно потім вже пошла
дезінформація суспільства а з різних
джерел на жаль і від яких журналістів
також тому ми особисто вдячний тим
журналістам які висвітлюють нашу позицію
дають нам можливість комунікувати з
суспільством
а на цьому в мене все і Пані Ірина ще
хотіла про про нашу спільну роботу
про про то щоб зронувати таку нормальну
ситуацію яка відбувається між
керівництвом ради яке блокує опозиційни
депутат насправді ми сьогодні говоримо
про кілька проблем і звичайно но Якщо
говорити про Угорщину то важливо
зазначити наступне очевидно Угорщина не
є
проукраїнською але для України це ну
критично Важливо не зробити з Угорщини
ворога Угорщина є членом
єснат наступного року в другій половині
2024 Угорщина головує в Європейському
Союзі і по суті от уже перемовини
почнуться про нашу адаптацію
законодавства виконання тих всіх 30 там
чотирьох кейсів необхідних для того
плану яки ми маємо виконати для того щоб
стати повноправним членом Європейського
Союзу почнуться саме під час головування
угощени і коли Прем'єр Угорщини Орбан
відверто говорить що у нього там ще буде
75 шансів заблокувати шлях України до ЄС
навіщо Україні дарувати 7 шостий якийсь
там ще шлях замість того аби робити все
щоби із непростої для нас столицею якою
безумовно є Будапешт е не всувати
взаємине навпаки знаходити комунікацію
Ми вітаємо той наприклад факт що зараз
Орбан заявив що він приймає запрошення
президента Зеленського до комунікації до
зустрічі це дуже важливо для України і
вважаємо що для України Взагалі в 2024
році коли так змінюється кон'юнктура
світу щодо нашої підтримки критично
важливим є розширювати цю підтримку а не
звужувати її і очевидно що і Владі і
нашим спецслужбам і всім нам треба бути
мудрішими І власне для цього дуже
важливо ми з вами спілкуємося в день
української дипломатії і принагідно ми
хочемо привітати українських дипломатів
послів українських які в важких умовах
весь цей два роки повномасштабного
вторгнення А до того іще ісм років війни
працюють максимально для підтримки
України для засудження Російської
Федерації але очевидно ми бачимо всі
ризики які сьогодні стоять перед нами як
державою для того аби не розпорошити цю
підтримку не втратити її повернуся до
цієї ганебної історії от ви знаєте
Україна почала зникати з міжнародних
медіа і тут вона знову з'явилась на
перших шпальтах на жаль не з
історіями про необхідність там про наших
героїв про те що відбувається на фронті
про те як треба посилити Україні
підтримку збройну А про скандали там
було було про посилення авторитарних
тенденцій про невипуск п'ятого
президента ми не тішимося циму не
тішимося цьму що всі світові медіа
написали про цю
історію Ну не думаю що це гарна реклама
українські Владі і от про це треба
думати Це дійсно спрацювало як іпсо
тільки це іпсо було влаштовано От людьми
які На жаль були долучені до цієї
операції і про проблема має системний
характер На жаль офіс президента дійсно
замість того аби усвідомлювати
важливість розширення дипломатичної
підтримки України посилення
міжпарламентської дипломатії сьогодні
сам формує ці списки депутатів кому
можна їхати у відрядження і відстоювати
Україну а кому за ро І от європейська
Солідарність знаходиться в цих чорних
списках Петру олексійовичу не вперше
заборонили виїзд за кордон я нагадаю
ганебна абсолютна історію коли єдиного
представника парламентської асамблеї
НАТО Петра Олексійовича не випустили Так
само на асамблею з такою ж самою
історією зіштовхнулася і я як співголова
фракції європейська Солідарність якали
на фракцію європейська Солідарність до
парламентської асамблеї обсі і ось
рішенням нчука мені було заблоковано
участь в осінній сесії парламентської
асамблеї ОБСЄ а також участь в
спостережній місії в Польщі знову Польща
знову Польща важлива для нас країна
ключова Країна де я була акредитована як
спостерігач в Центральній виборчій
комісії і мені було заблоковано це
відрядження так само як їм калижанками і
мені було заблоковане те саме
відрядження до Вашингтону для участі в
тій самій конференції idю міжнародний
демократичний Союз де ми мали десятки
зустрічей в держдепі в пентагоні
конгресі в сенаті з республіканцями з
конгресменами І в цей час табун з 30ти
слух І кілька товарищів з голоса вони
були в Сполучених Штатах дуже важливо
відзначити ми мали їхати за власний кошт
це відрядження в той час як та делегація
фінансувалися з видатків Верховної Ради
України і досі ми до речі не маємо
відповіді від пана степаанчука на наші
запити і звернення щодо фінансування цих
відряджень ми не дозволимо пану
стефанчуку який не є начальником жодному
народному депутату Він не є нам нашою
няній там інвестняній там чи я не знаю
чи вихователькою він є рівним серед
рівних і його задача - це організовувати
роботу Верховної Ради України ми не
дозволимо пану стефанчуку
сегрегувати діяльність депутатів
європейської солідарності і всередині
країни і назовні і то тому я хочу
подякувати нашим шановним адвокатам і
пану Ігорю і пану ілі які допомогли
підготувати депутатам європейської
солідарності позови до стефанчука до
окружного адміністративного суду Києва
це адміністративні позови щодо
протиправної бездіяльності посадової
особи якою є Голова Верховної Ради
України мені як співголові фракції він
заблокував відрядження також на
політичній асамблеї європейської
народної партії А ми є спостерігачем і
асоційованим членом цієї важливої
інституції І власне на політичних
асамблеях завжди приймаються резолюції
по Україні Ми спілкуємося там з нашими
партійними колегами І в цей час коли
мені було це заблоковано як співголові
фракції всі представники слуг народу
знаходились на з'їзді на політичній
асамблеї ліберальної партії тому що у
них є партійні зв'язки Скажіть будь
ласка це що таке очевид що це є
політично мотивовані дії це є політична
цензура це є подвійні стандарти і якщо
от випадку з Петром олексійовичем були
задіяні тут листи одне одному потім там
якісь переписки тут все набагато знаєте
і єзуїтськи відбувається Ти подаєш запит
на відрядження за здалегід за місяць з
усім пакетом заявою що там це за власний
рахунок запрошеннями і починається У вас
немає запрошення від спікера Ось вам
запрошення від спікера А у вас там немає
такого папе Ось вам весь пакет і далі Це
просто не підписується не підписується і
на наші всі звернення пане стефанчук
може ви якось відірветесь від
екселівської таблички де ви там галочки
ставите і Дасти відповіді депутатам
просто не дається відповідь що теж є
бездіяльність тому ми зібрали всі ці
пакети по кожному випадку і ще раз
хочемо зазначити що дивна історія
відбувається У пана степаанчука немає
жодних питань до представників опзж От
наприклад Михайлу папієву йому
підписують відрядження чи то Брюсель чи
то Вашингтон і там ніяких Ні іпсо тобі
немає ніяких там російських історій це
будь ласка і тільки до європейської
солідарності у стефанчука така знаєте
дуже дивна ставлення Я хочу нагадати що
ми не точно не кріпта щоби подобатись чи
не подобатись пану степанчуку і компанії
ми депутати і ми будемо виконувати наші
повноваження і захищати статус народного
депутата України і власне уже зараз Я і
Мої колеги ми готуємося до того що
А парламенти змінюються там знаєте
депутати змінюються але має залишитися
парламент як інституція дуже сильний і
важливо не дати його послабити тому ще
раз я хочу подякувати нашим адвокатам і
сказати що не тільки я подаю такий позов
до окружного адміністративного суду
Києва щодо пана стефанчука а щонайменше
вісім народних депутатів України
підготували такий пакет документів і ну
власне цього року ми завершимо цей
проект і цей процес і до мене і до наших
колег звертаються і депутати з інших
фракцій які ну абсолютно обуреня оцим
блокуванням міжпарламентської діяльності
депутатів з проханням Ну ви тримайтеся
боріться друзі Ми маємо разом
відстоювати сильний український
парламент і свободу слова і тому
звичайно якщо хтось хоче так само
доєднуватися до цієї важливої роботи ми
можемо тут вам в цьому сприяти останн
дру це дуже важливо да от ви знаєте
Сьогодні мав бути останній пленарний
день цього року п'ятниця мала бути
година запитань до уряду мали зачитати
запити але нічого цього не було Чому ви
запитаєте а тому що слуги розїхались Я
не знаю де вони но вже вчора там в на
якомусь етапі в залі не було необхідної
кількості голосів для прийняття рішень
Сьогодні у нас відбувалася замість
години запитань до уряду така маті
погоджувальної ради зустріч з
прем'єр-міністром з міністром фінансів з
міністром юстиції з міністром сільського
господарства де
ми обговорювали питання стану
української економіки викликів які
стоять перед країною на 24й рік я на що
звернула увагу що Серед лідерів фракцій
там були Ну доголі фракції Ну були
тільки ми всі інші це були вже на рівні
там заступників гулі фракцій Я не знаю
там представників фракцій на цій
зустрічі ще були присутні Петро
Порошенко і Ірина грайщенко може інші
вже роз'їхалися деж десь голови фракції
це до чого в наших планах кудись їхати
там На Різдво ми поїдемо на фронто
відрядження розумієте або на Новий рік
немає але ми нікому не дамо жодного
шансу блокувати важливі заходи за участі
європейської солідарності і наших
представників особливо коли мова йде про
міжпарламентські асамблеї делегації і
таке інше і тут ми будемо
захищати право наших виборців бути
представленими їх голос в усіх цих
делегацій
дякую